[Musique]
nous sommes sur la ligne de montage de
l'usiné psa de mulhouse chaque année ce
sont environ 250 milles nouvelle voiture
les peugeot 2008 des ds4 et des citroën
c4 qui empruntent ce chemin avant d'être
livrés à des clients répartis dans toute
l'europe ici les chiffres ont de quoi
donner le tournis croix-rouge
assemblages mécaniques et fonderies se
partagent un espace grand comme 440
terre de football 6500 personnes y
travaillent et dans le sud de l'alsace
près de 40000 serait impacté directement
ou indirectement par la présence du
constructeur automobile installée à
sausheim depuis 1961 l'usiné est un
élément structurant du territoire autant
qu'une fierté mais c'est la première
usine d de le tester cette importance
c'est quand même un secteur qui est
important pour notre canton
signe d'emplois c'est quand même une la
première ce premier employeur c'est
aussi le plus grand site industriel
d'alsace et vous le savez le troisième
site industriel de france après airbus à
toulouse et michelin voilà donc c'est
évidemment une fierté de compter sur ce
territoire à une usine comme celle de
mulhouse c'est déjà une image très
important et très positif pour notre
région est une grande fierté également
pour nous les élus et je pense pour même
toute la population mais c'est aussi de
la valeur ajoutée qui est créé sur le
territoire et à partir de là cette
richesse qui est générée sur le sur le
territoire elle bénéficie également aux
collectivités locales puisque à travers
les impôts économique psa est le premier
contribuable du département de
l'agglomération pour
les impôts locaux pourtant l approche du
cinquantenaire de lusine sont de
l'avenir devient incertain psa connaît
alors une véritable descente aux enfers
ou de production trop élevés repli du
marché européen l'entreprise est en
grande difficulté en alsace la possible
fermeture du site mulhousien est alors
dans toutes les têtes alors c'était un
sujet de grande inquiétude personne
n'ignore les grandes difficultés dans
lesquels psa se trouvait en 2011 2012
nous savons que c'est la marque entière
qui aurait pu basculer dans la faillite
et mulhouse était à l'époque l'une des
usines qui souffrait d'un vraiment de
compétitivité avec notamment celle
d'aulnay sous bois et on sait ce qui est
arrivé à aulnay-sous-bois en cas de
perte d'emploi c'est toute notre
économie qui aurait été remise en cause
c'était également pour nos collectivités
des places de crèches des fermetures
d'écoles qui ont été à prévoir un ça
aurait été catastrophique évidemment
pour les collectivités locales non
seulement en termes d'emploi mais
également de service public et donc pour
les élus il fallait tout faire pour que
le site de mulhouse puisse se pérenniser
il ya et puissent et bien maintenir sa
compétitivité
contrairement à aulnay mulhouse ne
fermera pas mais trop peu rentable usine
devra se moderniser une condition
indispensable à sa survie l'important
pour une usine française notamment et
pour l'outil industriel c'est d'être
usine la plus performante en europe dans
le monde pour ben garantir la pérennité
de cette usine et pour garantir cette
pérennité nous allons la moderniser nous
allons être dans le top 3 européen dans
le top 10 mondial ce qui nous garantira
les emplois de demain avec le soutien
des collectivités 850 millions d'euros
sont investis par psa pour moderniser
son usine odienne des travaux ont
commencé et alors que la ligne de
montage donc toujours on installe les
puits 2014 nous avons lancé une grande
rénovation notre usine en partant bien
sûr de l'existant pour aller vers l'
usine du futur alors l'usiné du futur
c'est quoi c'est simplement amener les
meilleures pratiques industrielles dans
notre usine que ce soit en termes
d'ergonomie que ce soit en termes de
baisse d'énergie que ce soit en termes
d'utilisation de l'outil digital aussi
bien pour produire pour maintenir nos
moyens industriels en termes techniques
c'est par exemple la tablette pour nos
responsables d'unité pour les aider à à
pouvoir faire leur tour de terrain sur
des outils digitaux
c'est le big data qui nous aide à
identifier des côtes où il a exploité
des codes informatiques pour améliorer
la qualité de nos voitures c'est aussi
des moyens dead à la maintenance pour
l'ensemble de nos maintenant ciel
objectif rendre l'outil industriel plus
flexible plus économes et plus efficace
par an nouvelles technologies de pointe
mulhouse devient ainsi un site pilote
pour l'ensemble du groupe ce qui est
développée ici pourrait bien être
l'avenir de toutes les usines le choix
de mulhouse pour porter cette importante
évolution technique ne doit en tout cas
rien au hasard si on a choisi mulhouse
pour servir de site pilote pour l' usine
du futur c'est que nous avons
aujourd'hui des compétences et des
collaborateurs qui permettent de le
faire ça c'est le premier point ensuite
évidemment que la situation géographique
au centre de l'europe avec les
autoroutes l'aéroport le ferroviaire
même le maritime font que nous avons une
situation privilégiée au sein de
l'europe
l'usiné sauver reste que les grandes
évolutions technologiques ne sont pas
toujours créatrice de plus d'emplois
elles peuvent même en réduire le nombre
une réalité que les élus du territoire
connaissent rien introduire le numérique
introduire davantage de robotique ça
veut forcément dire être plus
compétitifs mais parfois ça veut aussi
dire un peu moins d'emplois parce que
souvent les hommes sont remplacés par
des machines plus performantes et donc
il s'agit derrière également d'assurer
la pérennité de l'emploi mais ce que je
veux dire c'est que l'usiné du futur
elle est indispensable parce que si on
ne fait pas lusine du futur si on ne
modernise pas aujourd'hui nos usines eh
bien demain c'est la fermeture pure et
simple des usines avec la suppression de
tous les emplois parce que
malheureusement
les usines ne seront pas assez
compétitif par rapport aux autres usines
qui existent dans le monde pour nous les
perspectives sont tout à fait positive
encore une fois lusine se modernise et
donc cette modernité lui permet de
s'inscrire dans un avenir c'est à dire
d'être certain que les usines soient
toujours là dans 5 ans 10 ans ce qui est
essentiel pour le territoire et puis
derrière c'est bien sûr encore une fois
la question de l'emploi qui est
importante pour nous pour faire en sorte
que nous puissions avoir demain
les emplois au sein de l'usiné autour de
lusine crée également des entreprises
nouvelles sur le territoire où nos
jeunes pourront trouver un emploi dans
les dix prochaines années accompagner
les grandes industries dans leurs
mutations technologiques pour
sauvegarder l'existant mais aussi
favoriser une dynamique créatrice de
nouvelles entreprises voilà la mission
que se sont fixés les élus
départementaux pour sauvegarder l'emploi